DEFENSE DEPARTMENT TO GET THE
LIST OF ALL THE THINGS HE JUST
SAID.
>> Bill: THE MAJOR HEADLINE
$800 MILLION MORE IN AID AND
MORE COMING NOW THAT PUTS THE
UNITED STATES BASED ON MY
CALCULATION AT $3.3 ROUGHLY
BILLION, 56 DAYS INTO THIS WAR.
>> Dana: HE ALSO SAID THAT
THERE WOULD BE A BAN ON RUSSIAN
SHIPS COMING INTO AMERICAN
PORTS.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT EUROPE
HAS ALREADY DONE.
SO WE'RE SECOND TO THAT.
BUT THAT'S A SIGNIFICANT MOVE
NONETHELESS.
>> Bill: OTHER BIT OF NEWS ON
TITLE 42.
HE SAID THERE IS NO DECISION.
IN THE NEXT 4 1/2 WEEKS OR SO
IT COULD GO EITHER WAY.
THAT'S WHAT I TAKE AWAY FROM
THAT ANSWER.
>> Dana: SEE WHAT THE CDC SAYS.
KARL ROVE IS HERE.
HE LISTENED TO THE PRESIDENT'S
SPEECH AND GET YOUR INITIAL
REACTION, KARL.
>> Bill: I WOULD ADD ONE MORE
BIG ITEM FOR NEWS ITEMS IN THE
SPEECH.
HE WILL GO TO CONGRESS AND ASK
FOR A SUPPLEMENTAL BUDGET
APPROPRIATION FOR NOT ONLY
MILITARY ASSISTANCE BUT
ECONOMIC ASSISTANCE.
SAYING THAT HE HAD EXHAUSTED
THE EXISTING AUTHORITY VOTED BY
THE CONGRESS SO HE WILL GO BACK
FOR MORE.
I THINK THAT WAS ANOTHER
IMPORTANT THING.
>> Bill: KARL, THE WHITE HOUSE
NOTWITHSTANDING THE QUESTION
ABOUT MIGS OR JETS.
WE ARE SUPPLYING PARTS FOR
AIRPLANES BUT NOT THE PHYSICAL
JET THAT ZELENSKYY WANTS.
THEY HAVE BEEN CONSISTENT IN
SAYING IF THEY ASK FOR IT WE
GIVE IT TO THEM DEPENDING ON
THE NEEDS OF THE UKRAINIAN
MILITARY.
WHICH SEEMS TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION THAT WE'LL SATISFY
THEIR NEEDS FOR THE DAY
DEPENDING ON WHERE THE WAR IS.
WELL, I MEAN REWIND IN TIME.
IF YOU THOUGHT PUTIN WAS A BAD
MAN IN EARLY FEBRUARY, A LOT OF
THIS STUFF SHOULD HAVE BEEN
GOING INTO UKRAINE THEN AS
OPPOSED TO NOW IN LATE APRIL
AND INTO MAY.
>> I WOULD GO BACK IF WE WILL
BE CRITICAL LET'S GO BACK AND
BE EVEN MORE CRITICAL.
REMEMBER, LAST JUNE BEFORE AN
INTERNATIONAL MEETING WITH
PUTIN, PRESIDENT BIDEN PAUSED
U.S. MILITARY ASSISTANCE TO
UKRAINE AND DID NOT BEGIN TO
RENEW IT UNTIL NOVEMBER.
WE HAD JUNE, JULY, AUGUST,
SEPTEMBER, OCTOBER AND THEN
BEGINNING IN MID NOVEMBER WE
BEGAN THE RESUPPLY OF THEIR
MILITARY NEEDS AGAIN.
THAT FIVE-MONTH PERIOD OF WHERE
WE WERE SITTING ON THE
SIDELINES WAS PROBLEMATIC.
HAVING SAID THAT, WE DO NEED TO
GIVE THEM EVERYTHING THEY NEED
AND AS FAST AS WE POSSIBLY CAN.
IT IS MIND-BOGGLING TO ME AS
WHY WE'RE LAYING OUT WHAT WE'RE
GIVING THEM.
WE HAVE BEEN TELLING THE LATEST
TRAUN MUCH OF 800 MILLION
INCLUDES 155 MILLIMETER
ARTILLERY PIECES PLUS THE
PRESIDENT TODAY SAID WE'RE
SENDING 144,000 TACTICAL ROUNDS.
FOR EVERY RUSSIAN TANK WE'RE
SENDING 10 ANTI-TANK MISSILE
SYSTEMS.
MAYBE HE IS DOING THAT FOR
DOMESTIC PURPOSES.
NOT CERTAIN IT'S USEFUL TO DO
IT FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF
TELLING THE RUSSIANS WHAT WE'RE
DOING.
>> Dana: YOU PICKED UP ON
SOMETHING THAT I NOTICED.
THAT WAS THAT IN MANY OF HIS
SPEECHES AND NOT JUST ON THIS
TOPIC, STICK TO THIS ONE, HE
WILL GIVE A LAUNDRY LIST OF THE
STATISTICS AND THE NUMBERS.
AND HE BURIES THE LEAD.
AT THE END WHEN HE IS ASKED A
QUESTION ABOUT MARIUPOL, HE
SAYS MR. PUTIN BETTER NOT DO
THAT.
WHY DON'T YOU LEAD WITH THAT?
WHERE IS THE BIG OVERARCHING
THING.
IT SEEMS LIKE WE'RE PLAYING
WHACK-A-MOLE.
NOT GETTING AHEAD OF IT AND NOT
USING THE FULL WEIGHT OF THE
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> I COULDN'T AGREE MORE.
LOOK, WHAT WAS MISSING FROM
THIS?
WHAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT
TO KNOW AND HEAR FROM THEIR
PRESIDENT IS WHY DOES THIS
MATTER?
WHY ARE WE DOING THIS?
WHY IS VICTORY FOR THE
UKRAINIANS IMPORTANT TO THE
UNITED STATES?
AND IF HE WANTS TO SUSTAIN
PUBLIC SUPPORT, HE HAS TO GO
EXPLAIN THAT.
AND FRANKLY TODAY THERE WAS --
I GOT A LITTLE NERVOUS WHEN HE
SAID, YOU KNOW, OUR OBJECT IS
WE DON'T WANT THE RUSSIANS TO
TAKE ANY MORE TERRITORY.
TERRITORY.
OUR OBJECT NEED TO BE
UKRAINIANS WIN SO THE WORLD
DOESN'T HAVE TO LOOK OVER THEIR
SHOULDER OF PUTIN MOVING
FURTHER INTO EUROPE BY FORCE
AND BY TRYING TO HUMBLE HIS
NEIGHBORS.
SO YEAH, THEY PUT NUMBERS IN
THERE RATHER THAN STARTING WITH
AND ENDING WITH WHY IS THIS
IMPORTANT FOR AMERICA TO DO?
MAKE ONE OTHER OBSERVATION FROM
A COMMUNICATIONS PERSPECTIVE
AND SOME TREPIDATION BECAUSE
I'M THAN A PANEL WITH A GREAT
PRESIDENTIAL COMMUNICATOR.
WHY IS IT THAT WE JAM
EVERYTHING TOGETHER?
I THINK THEY ARE AFRAID OF --
HE COULD HAVE SAID SUPPLEMENTAL
MADE IT THE PURPOSE OF TODAY.
HE COULD HAVE SAID TOMORROW
WE'LL HAVE REFUGEE PROGRAM
AIMED AT THE CHILDREN.
MY SENSE IS THEY WANT TO TRY
AND AVOID TALKING ABOUT UKRAINE
SO THEY JAM EVERYTHING INTO ONE
DAY RATHER THAN EXPLAINING IT
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AS THEY
DEAL WITH EACH ONE OF THESE
THINGS.
SO I THINK THEY ARE CONCERNED
IF THEY TALK ABOUT UKRAINE TOO
MUCH IT WON'T ALLOW THEM TO
TALK ABOUT THE BUILD BACK
BETTER AGENDA AND UNIVERSAL
PRE-K-AND FREE FAMILY PAID
LEAVE AND BLAH BLAH BLAH THAT
IS GOING NOWHERE BUT THEY THINK
IT IS IMPORTANT FOR THEIR
POLITICAL CHANCES IN NOVEMBER.
>> Dana: EVERYTHING IS THROWN
IN IN ONE SPEECH.
>> Bill: HE SAID PUTIN WON'T
CONTROL ALL OF UKRAINE.
WE'LL BE PICKY ON LANGUAGE
THAT'S A CONCESSION OF SORTS.
ALL OF UKRAINE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
ABSOLUTELY.
I COULDN'T AGREE MORE.
THIS IS WHY WE NEED TO SAY OUR
OBJECT IS UKRAINE TO WIN NOT TO
SORT OF SUGGEST TO PUTIN WE'RE
WILLING TO ALLOW HIM TO
CONTINUE TO NIBBLE.
>> Dana: IMAGINE THEY WILL BE